when Muriel came your way where were you
in life you were an actress you'd done a
movie already right yeah I I'd done that
one film Spotswood um I think I was
delivering
pizzas I had um I'd been to naida which
then is the National Institute of
dramatic art in Sydney and whilst there
in my second year I was offered to leave
and work at the Sydney theater company
with a brilliant theater director called
Neil Armfield playing Sonia in Uncle van
opposite Jeffrey rush and um I couldn't
say no it was a big leap because they
make you feel like drama school is
everything um but I remember talking to
my then agent and she it was a year away
from Muriel's Wedding and I said I don't
want to leave do the play and then not
have anything else to do and she said
well there is this one thing waiting to
be financed you know G me a basic
description of it weirdly a year later I
was just thinking I wonder what happened
to that called her and she was like this
is crazy timing because it is happening
and she was going to call me about it oh
you're kidding